we're all going through the same thing
which is total lockdown
and you are in this fairly isolated
community
what are you doing to pass the time are
you doing anything now
that you wouldn't normally do uh
well i've been stir crazy like everybody
else uh
and i also made the habit of buying
more stuff than i needed like online you
know like see some control
um but then i noticed which i've never
noticed before it's so much time that
you get like a sometimes a follow-up
email
asking to review the product that you've
bought
and so i've started answering them
with with my actual opinion of the
products yeah well here's the
interesting thing i found out about this
and uh i think we have one of these and
i want to show it because
i i i really love it we have a birthday
cake flavor of magic spoon and you
you wrote i just love it so much i ate
it all up oh baby did
it taste good give me more more and more
the more boxes in my pantry the more i'm
feeling happy
exclamation point and then hot patootie
but then you sign it jason siegel the
actor
yeah well i love that you're signing
them
[Laughter]
you know you could be anonymous but
you're going the other way
you know i gotta tell you it gives me
such joy like even hearing it read back
i had such a good time every single one
that i've written i've had a really
really good time with
yeah you wrote this one for the uh uh
you you bought a uh
bathtub caddy and you wrote i love my
damn bathtub caddy
when i'm washing up after a hard day
having all my goodies just to toe pinch
away as all this big guy has ever wanted
yippee best jason siegel
the actor
i love that i just picture someone
reading that and feeling really good
about what they've made
you know i think that's very nice of you
i'm just curious
if i were you i'd start ordering pizzas
and before you even put in your order
just say hi this is jason siegel the
actor
yeah let's do that most times yeah i
i've been doing that for about 20 years
that's fantastic you're very you're very
comfortable with your fame